is
[Music]
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this press conference
good afternoon everybody uh thank you
very much they landed 20 minutes ago
literally
um i'm very happy to be back and to see
you all
just to give you a bit of context
before
you ask
questions that you may have
as you know
you were
i went to ukraine
and i
visited the
south
nuclear power plant
well i had a number of meetings with the
minister of energy
of ukraine with the
head of the
nuclear company and ergo atom
and of course with the ukrainian
regulator
there and some
technical people from the
from the station
the city was very important not only to
analyze the situation over there but in
a in a wider
sense
to discuss
the next steps that we are planning to
take
the next measures that we are going to
be proposing
um
to continue our work on on safety and
security
there
having completed
that part of the of the trip
and
i moved on to uh
russia federation
to uh canadian grad
where i met with
the
director general of uh
rosatom corporation
representatives of the russian ministry
foreign affairs
and also the russian regulator
and there we also
discuss
some of these
issues from of course their perspective
the work with this
the work
started
and we are going to be continuing
in the next few days
so this is the context and
having said that
i am uh at your disposal for any
questions that you may have
do you have any questions yes
hi dg possible murphy from reuters hello
hello
um
uh
i feel like everything is a little
confusing at the moment so perhaps we
can straighten a few a few things out um
first of all
you're on one hand there's this idea of
the framework agreement and then on the
other there's the assistance that you're
providing so initially it sounded like
you wanted a framework agreement before
you could provide assistance
but then you announced that you were
starting some assistance the moment you
arrived in ukraine
it sounds like talks on the train march
agreement are continuing so could you
tell us
what a do you provide do you intend to
provide overall
how much of that has already been
provided yes
and where are you on the framework
agreement
thank you very much very pertinent
question
i i perhaps
i would
kindly ask you to bear with us if in the
middle of a
you know military conflict we cannot be
as orderly
and systematic as would be
desirable in peace time so not always
everything goes as implied because
there is
this dissipation but let me say
the
initially yes
there was this idea of having a an
agreed framework
that would be
accepted by all and and this was part of
a number of consultations that that i
had
as in any diplomatic process where
different options were were considered
and initially uh
there was an idea to have something
trilateral then to have it codified
separately
but
the reality is that
the there were a number of observations
on the impact of this kind of approach
on other political matters and i took
the decision that what's important here
is to work on the nuclear safety and the
security of the plants i have said from
day one that there is a real risk
and that my
intention was not to engage in a process
of negotiating drugs after drafts after
drafts of a paper it doesn't make any
sense in the circumstances so
i do have if you want an agreed
framework i do have it but the
difference is that we have agreed
separately
with russia and with ukraine on what we
are going to do and this does not
require
to agree on the wording of a specific
document that doesn't mean that we are
acting
out of thin air
we have a very detailed list of
activities that have been
agreed with ukraine on the basis of a
document about purely technical nature
and i can describe that to you
if you are interested
the
assistance has started actually
because
we
i mean in in my trip i i took with me uh
some radiation monitoring equipment
portable and and of a different nature
uh which is needed in different
different locations there so one can say
that um
we have started that
in terms of the
um of the activities and the assistance
that we are going to be providing
it has many aspects
it has many aspects there is one that
has to do with uh advice and support
which is being given remotely by our
teams from from vienna some of these
have has started but we still needed to
discuss with them on
some specific
issues that were that were necessary so
this is one thing the second is that is
in the area of delivery of equipment
delivery of equipment as i told you
has also
started
but we do have they they do have needs
there are needs that we also want to
assess
from
our own perspective we also have a very
important number of
countries member states that are
offering us
assistance
but of course this need this needs
support
we have to reconcile what our ukrainian
colleagues
need with what is available and and have
us as a bridge
and as a technical advisor to do that
there is another
area which is of course very very
important
which has to do with with the physical
presence of iaea experts and inspection
safeguards
on site at different places we also
discussed
about this we are not of course planning
to have large numbers of people out
there
we are discussing what kind of
specialties what kinds of expertise may
be needed and this of course is
different if you're talking about
chernobyl or if you're talking about
malinsky or if you're if you're talking
about regna or south it depends uh on
each one of those so we have
agreed
about that as well there are a number of
logistical considerations as you can
imagine my own trip
had lots of them because of the reality
on the ground with an ongoing i must say
military conflict and i i want to remind
you that i went to the nuclear power
plant which is closest to the uh
to the war zone right
so that is another thing and finally and
i believe quite importantly we agreed to
have um
a rapid assistance um mechanism
which means that in case
and hopefully this one won't be
happening in case there was a situation
an emergency
that may be taking place
we are setting up a mechanism whereby we
could be sending a team to assess and to
assist almost immediately so as you can
see there is a lot
of uh
i would say
different
groups of activities that we are
undertaking under each one of these
headings that i'm giving you you can
decline them into
a good number of more specific tasks
that are going to be
undertaken
so i hope this long answer provides some
clarity in what
we have been doing
perhaps you could just give us a vague
idea of how far along you are in because
you know you've mentioned you've
mentioned before that you have very
specific plans for what you want to do
there these are plans i understand that
so how far along are we now so what you
know the plan
the plans are there and we are we are
starting next week
but you said when you arrived there that
you were starting then so how far along
are we in deployment starting with a
number what we did was
deliver some equipment
this is a start
but we have a structured
set of activities that are going to
start as of next week
hello uh
a german press agency uh thanks for this
explanation i still have some follow-up
questions or things or not i don't
really understand
first of all what kinds of parts are you
are you supplying
and second of all what kind of advice or
what kind what is the purpose of the
missions that you're planning to send
because i assume that ukraine has a very
high level of you know nuclear expertise
so why do they need the ia at this point
and is it also the case that a kind of a
continuous
presence even if it's a small presence
of ia experts on the ground provides an
addition
because of your international nature of
the ia provides some kind of symbolic
protection
no well
yeah this needs this needs to be
terrified first of all
on your point about the them having a
lot lots of expertise and thereby if i
infer correctly not needing
the iaea well that could be applied to
the rest of 173
member states and the iaea perhaps could
not even be necessary we are providing
consultancy and advice sorry service to
dozens of countries around the world and
the fact that you have the expertise
does not mean that you have a problem
you want to check against the standards
you want to check
good practices around the world you want
to check
if
something has been done has been done
before
you have i mean this kind of is activity
is normal
in the life of the iaea we are in a
constant
interaction
with our
with the technical experts of every
member states let alone ukraine
in a military conflict so it is
absolutely needed there are i also i
would also like to
remind you uh humbly that
what's happening there has never
happened before
so many things
that may be
um
this disconnected or or
out of service
because of a number of reasons
interruption of power um or
physical damage maybe have never
happened before
and we can
provide them with advice compare it's
not that they need us to do their job
they they do know how to do their job
but this doesn't mean that there is not
a lot of international assistance and
cooperation ongoing in this case
in particular so this is very very
important in the case of the physical
presence the physical presence has
a number of dimensions i would say
in the first place it is about doing a
job faster because you are there and our
people can interact from there can
interact with the technical teams over
here and that makes the whole process
far more efficient
so this is one dimension another
dimension which is very very important
is the dimension of the briefings and
information you may have seen
from the
month more or less that we have had
since this situation started that on
occasion it has been a bit
laborious for us to establish facts by
having people there this process also
goes much faster and if we have a
a problem in one area then our people
there can consult with the people at the
plant and and make it much much faster
so it is in this
sense that the presence of the iaea
experts
is our own site
it is
important so i hope this more or less
clarifies these two points that you
missed
and one other point when it comes to
safeguards
it is very important to be reminded that
because the list is conflict
and again this is one of the very
unprecedented features of this situation
we have these plants many of them
running
and the nuclear material is there and it
needs to be verified and there are
activities
guided or or
imposed by the operational needs of
these facilities that must be verified
and in some cases as it was the case for
chernobyl
remote
monitoring capabilities have been
interrupted
and as you know because you're experts
and you have been following other
safeguards and
non-proliferation cases that we have
some things can only be done by our
experts and external
actors including those who are hosting
and having their facilities cannot
tamper with our equipment so there is
this also this non-proliferation
dimension which is not
frequently uh mentioned
not perhaps logically but
it is not
it's nonetheless very important for us
so as you can see there are many many
reasons why our presence there is so
important
thank you
yes
thank you very much hi
michael about the childhood
as
power
said yesterday he was written and
ukraine authorities shared this
information the russian uh forces left
this uh power plan what is the last
situation there first question second
question
these steps by the uh russian
authorities was a little bit
in my eyes uh was a little bit
unexpected
uh it is uh
it is about
how can i say that you use [ __ ] with
both type and it it was on the table
this issue you need to speak with the
russian authorities about this
and how can we see this as steps it
could be a
positive uh sound to the other uh power
plants for instance the uh zomboricio
you know i don't i don't know
yeah yes we have a uh a
positive uh
or positive a sign that the russian
forces
left also this uh power plant thank you
for those who are not thank you for the
question for those who are not in the
conduction of a war any step may be
unexpected we we don't we do not know
what the next step will be what we know
is what we want to see
as far as excuse me as far as the
nuclear power
facilities in
in ukraine is concerned and this is
undoubtedly a step in the right
direction
we have been saying that the plant
needed to be operated by their own by
its own natural operators which was the
case that it had to have a physical
integrity protected that the people
there had to work in under normal
circumstances which were not of course
present where you had
falling
troops controlling and checking et
cetera
you perhaps you remember the issue of
the shifts of the personnel which were
not
being done so it is obvious that we were
raising this issue from day one
day one of the occupation of this uh
plant which was did not coincide with
the operation with the start of the of
the of the military actions there so uh
we see this uh of course as a step in
the right direction we are going to be
there very very soon
uh because there is a internally there
is a lot of work uh to be done
um and uh so we we hope to be able to
start this technical work in these areas
that i was addressing in the previous
questions
hello
i have a couple of questions
just for the leaders to understand when
we talk about the equipment are we
talking about like these more about
diesel
generator or the fuel itself or
what are you apart from the uh the
portable uh video
what what else
can you say that you're providing that's
question number one question number two
is that
it seems like you're going to
have to do the whole counting of the
nuclear material in chernobyl because
the data is not there so you just want
to go there and make sure that
everything is as it is as before yes now
how long would that take and then how
many manpower you need
that's question number two and are you
going to do you have a plan to
strengthen the monitoring system uh
apart from what you have now yes uh the
number three is uh you are putting a lot
of people internally
now so did you get a sort of clear
assurance
from the russian side although that the
whole framework is not agreed
but
may we assume that they said that it's
okay for you guys to go in
thank you
very good a lot lots of important
aspects here in terms of the equipment
it does include what you would mention
it may be including
other
bigger parts but i would like to be
prudent at the moment um because we have
to reconcile
the the list that
our ukrainian
counterparts have given us with what we
have and we are in discussion so it
would not be correct for me to say
exactly what we are planning to provide
until we have an agreement
with them they are the the interested
party if you want they are sharing with
us
lists which are quite detailed and go
beyond
personal and radiation monitoring
equipment i cannot show you but we have
to agree with that before this this can
be
there's nothing
i would say
mysterious about it it's normal safety
equipment
but
we need to agree with them in terms of
the nuclear material
yes we are going to we can do that
relatively quickly we
we do not
feel
we have a clear idea of what is there as
you know spent fuel pumps and and in
other
places at the chernobyl so it's
something that can be done
it has to be done rather quickly if you
remember when i give it
when i came
when i came back from antalya i told you
something like this and as you can see
this is ultra normal okay so we have
been using
um
assessment
quite quite consistently and this is
what we need to restore
so
it doesn't mean that we are not
registering things we have to reconnect
some things and it can be done quite
quite you know quickly i don't
have a problem
about that
or a doubt about that but of course it
needs to be done and the sooner the
better the sooner the better
then the your other your other question
is a bit more um difficult to answer
because what you are asking me is
whether we have full assurances
that everything is going to be fine
we are going to get us
as good as an assurance as we can
because as i said i would not put my
stuff in harm's way
but we need to recognize that
that there is an armed conflict and
there is shelling and there and so
we need to
have secure routes we need to have
protection we need to have zones that
are deconflicted
uh to
move uh through
so
we are very serious about this
we are of course we have our own
security capabilities we have
we are in contact with the ukrainian
authorities which have been supporting
for example my
my trip now
and of course we are talking to the
russian side we are talking to you in
security i i benefited and i take
advantage of the occasion to to thank
again the secretary general who
gave me his full support of the united
nations i mean
who gave me his full support and and
provided
some
armored vehicles for us to move around
so all these things can be done but you
need to take lots of precautions and we
are going to be doing that yes
hello
hello
thank you very much for doing this and
welcome back i want to come back to
chernobyl you met the russian
authorities today is there any i mean
did they tell you why they left
chernobyl is there a technical nuclear
aspect is it just a military security
reason you might probably not have
spoken about it
and do you and your experts believe that
you can in the next few days confirm or
not confirm if hundreds of russian
soldiers have been contaminated around
chernobyl is there
what's your analysis of
how quickly you can confirm that thank
you very much uh yeah
on the on why they left was we
they didn't discuss that with me i think
this is a decision by
military authorities and it was not on
the table it's not the kind of thing
that we were
discussing on the issue of radiation we
are already in consultation
with the
with the ukrainian side and also we
offer
the russian colleagues if there is any
information that they want to share with
us as you know and this has been under
the
general consideration for some weeks now
the the general uh radiation situation
around the plant plant is quite normal
there was a relatively relatively higher
level
of
localized radiation because of the
movement of heavy vehicles
at the time of the occupation of the
plant and apparently this might have
been the case again in the way
out so
we heard about the possibility of some
personnel being contaminated but we
don't have any confirmation about that
and we have a lot of expertise in-house
to help if that
if that was required uh from us but
none of these reports uh have been
confirmed
i have identity care
thank you very much for doing this so
quickly
and
a few questions if i made uh
can you confirm the equipment and the
personnel are you planning to send those
to
every nuclear facility in ukraine
including chernobyl
secondly
are you
disappointed by the fact that this
broader framework
seemingly isn't going to be happening
what would you characterize as the main
obstacles to that
and lastly i wonder if you might give us
just a general impression of how you
found
the situation on the ground in ukraine
in terms of you know your colleagues
from
the ukrainian regulator the people who
are at the power plants there obviously
it's an extremely difficult situation
for them
how how are they bearing up how how is
lifestyle
okay thank you for the question
regarding the equipment yes i do hope to
be able to deliver the equipment at
every place wherever it's needed
given the circumstances of different
facilities this may require different
approaches
different approaches
the case of chernobyl is one thing in
the case of
the the other power plants
there is the distance and there is the
military situation one of the plants
remains
under the control of the russian forces
so that that will undoubtedly require a
different a different approach but
nothing makes me think that
there will be any possibility to to do
that if i'm disappointed about the
agreed framework as i said
no because first of all
we have we have an agreement we do have
a framework we don't we do not have that
element but let me tell you um
a good diplomat has has a good
toolbox
and when one uh
tool doesn't work you take another
until you get what you want so i'm not
enamored with anything the important
thing is that the tool that you take
does the job and what we have now is
doing it is doing the job
and then uh
however of course you know the human
aspects are very important you may have
seen me
talking to the
staff
i really wanted to do this to express
my admiration to them the recognition
that we all feel for for their
um for the the situation they are going
through right now
but i can say i saw them very determined
i saw them working well i saw them
also converted to see that the iaea is
there
side by side offering assistance
being present
so
my impression of course
within the
due respect that we must have for an
ongoing conflict that is bringing a lot
of suffering
i i came back with a with a positive
feeling in the middle of this
tragedy which is always war
the very complete
that's also every site if needed surely
when it comes to personnel you could
send that also to every site you can
send that to every site if necessary or
you can take it
through the episode every site every
this is something that we are going to
be deciding with
with the ukrainian
authorities
we have our ideas we
we shared with them ideas and a program
but they have to look at it
and tell us what what they want and in
the order that they want
thank you we can take one more question
over there yes hi honorable
media and my question actually with
concerns the the negotiation with the
russians
can we know what did you speak with them
is there a possibility that actually the
nuclear plants uh will be ensured like
natural zones in the future
also there's question concerning this
ukraine uh stuff that is working in the
third plan do they actually want to be
there
what if the nuclear plant
uh would stay properly without any stuff
will you provide actual mila
to stop there uh if if this happens also
the question uh is coming up um
um is there some third part that
as we have heard
some uh
some things are gone from nuclear plants
uh who took them and how it will be
investigated is there a possibility that
is taken actually by other parts not the
ukrainian or russian part what do you
mean things that happen
um
there's uh
as we heard some new club materials
is that true they are not away from the
plant we don't have information about
material disappear okay thank you
but it's a regular thing and it has to
it
and i think it's it's
it's very relevant in the context of my
previous comments about the safeguards
activities that we need to perform we
need to continue performing
all our activities so that we can
give the credible assurances that that
is going to be is going to be the case
uh so that is one thing regarding the
the the
nuclear power plants and
they've been neutral et cetera it's not
something that is for for the iaea to
discuss the you know territorial
arrangements what we have said is of
course that
they have to be um
their their physical integrity needs to
be protected at all times and that any
any attack or any physical action
against a nuclear facility is of course
unacceptable and i think this is
something that everybody agrees on and i
hope that is the case and if it doesn't
happen the iea will be saying that
regarding the staff i haven't heard
anybody saying that they want to leave
the stations or that they are
uncomfortable
working working there
so
if you bear with me i have to
close a very important conference that
has been ongoing in my absence
so
i want at least to show respect for
those who were there at the conference
and process i thank you for continuing
uh following this issue as as i said in
the beginning i think that we are going
to be moving
to chernobyl very very soon and we are
going to be informing you
about that i wish you all a nice evening
thank you very much